- [Instructor] Today, we're going to talk
about biodiversity.
So biodiversity as you might've guessed
comes from two words,
biological and diversity.
And essentially, it's the variations
or the diversity present
between living things.
Now, I grew up in the
sunny state of Arizona.
And at first glance,
there doesn't seem to be much variety
in such a hot and dry place.
I mean, it's the desert, right?
But if we take a closer look
at a place such as the Sonoran Desert,
and here's a picture,
we would find all kinds
of different living things
like saguaro cacti,
jackrabbits, tarantulas,
silver-haired bats and the roadrunner,
which is my personal favorite.
So we can say that the desert
is actually quite biodiverse.
So in other words,
it's home to a large
variety of living things.
Since there are both big
and small differences
between different living things,
we can think of biodiversity
on three different levels.
So the first and smallest scale level
is going to be genetic biodiversity,
which is just the genetic variation
within a group of organisms.
And a really great example
of this kind of biodiversity
is the rock pocket mouse.
And I know, that's a
mouthful of words to say.
But it's really cute.
I mean, look at this picture.
So this is a species that can
actually be found right here
in the Sonoran Desert.
And the cool thing
about this mouse species
is that there exists both tan
and black-colored rock pocket mice.
So even though both colored rodents
come from the same species,
there are genetic biodiversity
creates mice with
completely different traits.
And what's even more awesome
is the fact that these
colors, tan and black,
have come about due to natural selection.
So scientists have found
that there are more
black-colored rock pocket mice
in places with dark black-ish lava rock.
While there are more
tan-colored rock pocket mice
in lighter colored sands.
And this makes sense because
if you think about it,
the mice are hunted from
above by predators like birds.
So having a coat color that
blends into their surroundings
would increase their chances of survival.
So having this kind of genetic
biodiversity is really great,
because the rock pocket mice
can use many different colored
landscapes as habitats.
And if let's say the
landscape color were to change
and suddenly become
dominated by dark lava rock,
then this population of mice
would have the genetic diversity
that it needs to adapt to this change.
So the second level is
species biodiversity,
which is the variety of
species in a particular area.
So going back to the Sonoran Desert,
there are all kinds of mammals and birds,
plants, and insects.
But what I think is
even more mind boggling
is the sheer number of
bat species there are.
I mean, we have silver-haired
bats, as I mentioned earlier.
But also bats like spotted
bats, Western red bats,
and even this kind of bat
called Peter's ghost-faced bat,
which I think is a really awesome name.
And you're probably thinking, okay, Abby,
this is really interesting.
But so what?
Well, like genetic biodiversity,
species biodiversity is
super duper important.
Because having a lot of different species
means that more roles can
be filled in an ecosystem,
which makes the ecosystem healthier.
So moving on to the final level,
we have ecosystem biodiversity.
And this is just the variety
of ecosystems on the planet.
Now we've been talking a lot
about the Sonoran Desert.
And a desert is actually a
type of ecosystem on earth.
And if you recall,
ecosystems are made up
of both living things
and their physical environment.
So in this case, living
things in the desert ecosystem
could include things like
rattlesnakes, scorpions,
and cacti.
Well, non-living things
could include rock formations
or a sand dunes.
And in addition to desert ecosystems,
earth has forest ecosystems,
coral reef ecosystems,
all kinds of different ecosystems.
And having all these
different kinds of ecosystems
is extremely critical for our survival.
Because the diversity
of ecosystems on earth
provide us humans with important
resources and services.
So without ecosystem biodiversity,
our quality of life,
and in fact, our very
survival could be at risk.
So as you can tell, every
level of biodiversity
is incredibly important
for unique reasons.
Now, biodiversity doesn't remain constant.
So we can think of biodiversity
as something that can change over time.
Now, the important thing to remember
is that speciation increases biodiversity
while extinction decreases biodiversity.
So let's talk about speciation first.
So speciation happens when
one species evolves into two
or more species over time.
And you might have heard
or seen something that looks like this.
And I'll draw it out
right here to the right.
And this is just a very
simple speciation model
or a phylogenetic tree.
So we have here a common ancestor
that branches off into
different species over time.
This arrow representing
time or T for short.
And it's speciation events like these
that have led to the biodiversity
that we see on earth today.
On the flip side, we have extinction
which causes biodiversity to decrease.
And what we mean by this word
extinction is that a species
or population of living
things dies off completely.
So notice that it can happen
on different levels too.
For example, if a population goes extinct,
then we no longer have the
genetic variants in the gene pool
or the set of genes for
a particular species.
But if a species went extinct entirely,
then that species is no longer there
to fulfill its unique role
or its ecological niche.
So you might've heard of the dodo bird,
which is a species that
actually went extinct
way back in the 1600s.
So, some of the major causes
behind the dodo birds extinction
include over hunting, habitat loss
and competition with some
newly introduced species.
And unfortunately, the last dodo bird
was reportedly killed in 1681.
And even though we can't enjoy
the presence of dodo birds anymore,
learning about this extinct bird
actually brings up a really good question.
That is, what effect do humans have
on biodiversity right now?
Well, it's sad to say,
but humans are actually causing
biodiversity to decrease.
Things like climate change,
habitat destruction,
and overexploiting resources
have caused a huge loss of biodiversity.
And if you remember having biodiversity
is really critical to our survival,
which is a big, oh, oh.
In fact, species extinction
is now occurring at a rate
of 100 to 1000 times faster
than the background rate
detected in fossil records.
And because the extinction rate
is much bigger than the speciation rate,
the result is an overall loss
or decrease in biodiversity.
So today we learned about biodiversity,
which is the variety of
life present on earth.
We talked about three different
levels of biodiversity
moving from genetic
biodiversity to species
and then ecosystem biodiversity.
And we also talked about how
biodiversity isn't stagnant
or fixed in place.
We have speciation events
that can increase biodiversity
and extinctions that
decrease biodiversity.
And finally, we learned that human actions
are threatening biodiversity,
as we currently have a
greater extinction rate
than speciation rate.